เฮ
[música]
Olá [música]
queridos ouvintes, espectadores do
Calgente. Aqui é Gregório do Viv. Hoje é
segunda-feira, dia 8 de dezembro de 2025
e vou chamar aqui meus amigos Alessandro
Orufino e Bruno Torturra. Como é que
vocês estão? Estão bem?
>> Oi, Greg. Oi,
>> oi, pessoal. Tudo bem? Tudo certo?
Segunda-feira, 8 de dezembro, o ano tá
acabando, não é? Vem chegando o verão,
como diria Claudinho Buchecha, claro,
perdão, Marina Lima citando Claudinho
Buchecha.
>> Vem chegando o verão. O calor no
coração, calor danado no Rio de Janeiro.
>> Alessandra não, Alessandra tá no frio,
até porque está ganhando um prêmio.
Ganhou o prêmio de melhor produção e
melhor roteiro no Festival Internacional
de Documentários. Sim, Alessandra e
Petra Costa ganharam pelo filme
maravilhoso Apocalipse nos Trópicos. Se
você não viu, corre para ver Apocalipse
nos Trópicos, que é um filme, um
documentário maravilhoso, viu, que você
pode encontrar aí na Netflix.
>> Na Netflix,
>> lembrando que hoje tem o documentário
dela e aparentemente meio que é todos os
filmes do mundo hoje em dia, né?
>> É. A do dia ou ainda não se fechou?
>> Ainda não. Ainda não saiu
>> não. Eles não compraram.
Eles anunciaram que vão comprar. É C.
Verdade. [risadas]
Verdade.
>> Tava achando. É a gente quer saber o
>> a gente quer saber se o Greg News vai
para Netflix, entendeu? Essa é a nossa
única dúvida sobre esse merger. A gente
vai mandar um e-mail pro FCC e falar:
"Queridos americanos do FCC, a única
dúvida relevante sobre esse mergers and
acquisitions é se o Greg News vai estar
disponível na Netflix".
E falando em filme, ano que vem a gente
vai estar com o nosso clube de cultura,
não é só um clube do livro, é um clube
de cultura do Calmente, onde a gente vai
assistir filmes juntos, não só filmes,
como séries, como ouvir álbuns, discos,
a gente vai ouvir fitas, cassetes, todas
as mídias, a gente vai estar junto ano
que vem. Você pode se inscrever no nosso
clube de cultura. Sim, lá no
calmorgente.com, não é?
>> Uhum. Você vai lá no cant.com e pode se
inscrever. Tem inscrições limitadas,
então corre antes que acabe pra gente
passar o ano que vem juntos discutindo
não somente livros, mas cultura de modo
geral. E falando nisso, vamos entrar no
tema da semana que é o assustador, o
macabro, o fúnebre mercado de previsões.
Por que fala disso? Porque ã tem uma
empresa, talvez você tenha visto aí, que
a primeira bilionária selfmade
brasileira eh surgiu nos Estados Unidos.
Sim, eu tô usando o termo da, tá, pelo
amor de Deus, o termo das notícias. Eu
não sabia que existia esse conceito de
othermade bilionária, mas sim,
aparentemente todas as bilionárias
brasileiras até então eram other people
made, agora ela é selfmade, tá? Sim. Tem
uma bilionária brasileira que fez a
própria fortuna. Isso virou notícia. Ela
fez a própria fortuna porque ela tá
bilionária em dólar. O nome dela é Luana
Lopes Lara. E como foi que ela ficou
bilionária e virou essa ídola, sobretudo
da de uma direita, não é, que da Jovem
Pan e tudo estão falando. Viva nova
bilionária brasileira. Brasil paralelo
fez quase um documentário sobre ela.
Vocês viram sobre essa selfmade
billionaire que é a Luana Lapis Lara.
Como foi que ela chegou lá? Ela chegou
lá eh virando sócia, quer dizer,
criando, né? cocriando junto com o Tark
Mansur, que é um um cara, enfim, enfim,
fez MIT com ela. Esse cara, eles criaram
uma coisa chamada Cusi. O que que é a
CAI? É um, é uma empresa de supostas
previsões, na verdade, de apostas, né? É
um site no qual você pode entrar e
apostar sobre mercados, que é o que eles
chamam de mercados, né? São perguntas
que você tem que responder ali e
apostar. Então eles vão dizer que não é,
mas para mim é tipo uma bet de qualquer
coisa, porque bet é de futebol e eles
não fazem tanto futebol, é mais
política, mas então, por exemplo, bombou
nas eleições americanas, quem vai ser o
novo presidente americano? Biden ou
Trump? Você ia lá e Camala ou Trump?
Você ia lá, votava e ganhava um dinheiro
se você acertasse. É um mercado de
apostas, só que eles chamam de previsão.
Você vai lá, C não é a única, tá? Tem
outras, entre elas a Polyarket, que
talvez seja a maior no Brasil é a maior
certamente. E a Polyarket, então você
pode apostar mesmo qualquer coisa. Tem
lá uma aposta que tá bombando, que é o
mandame vai ser deportado até o fim
desse ano. Você vai lá e aposta e tem
uma, alguns porcentos de pessoas estão
votando que sim. Qual vai ser? né? Vai
ter um surto de sarampo nos Estados
Unidos até o final desse ano. Coisas
desse tipo. Apostas sobre qualquer
coisa. É meio que uma bet de tudo.
Contrariamente as bets, ã, e é isso que
eles alegam para se separar das bet, que
não pega muito bem hoje em dia você ser
bet. Elas são proibidas inclusive em
vários estados dos Estados Unidos. A Bet
é proibida nos Estados Unidos, tá? O
paraíso lá liberal deles proibiu bet em
vários estados. Ah, até para driblar
essa proibição, a Caus, que que fez? tá
dizendo que não é bet porque, e a
diferença deles é a seguinte, nós não,
ninguém aposta contra a gente, porque
uma bet, foi o que eu aprendi no no Greg
News de Bet, que vocês podem lá ver,
inclusive, uma bet, ela define quanto
que tá pagando. Então, ela diz assim:
"Olha,
você eh quer apostar no Flamengo? Tá
bom, tô pagando dois para um, eu tô
pagando." Você aposta contra a casa e
ela tem um algoritmo genialmente pensado
para ganhar sempre. Ela ganha, não
sempre, claro, mas ganha a maioria das
vezes. É por isso que elas são
bilionárias, porque elas têm um
algoritmo genial que em geral vai fazer
você ganhar. E claro, a margem, elas
elas tem sempre uma margem, né, de
lucro. Então, elas vão pagar um pouco
menos do que elas, perdão, elas vão elas
vão pagar menos do que elas vão receber.
Claro, a o OD é sempre melhor. Enfim,
por que que eu tô falando isso? Porque
as casas de apostas, as novas casas de
aposta, Caus, Polyarketing, elas não
você não aposta contra a Polyarket,
contra a CA. Elas só criam a pergunta, o
mercado, você aposta contra outra
pessoa? Então você, o que você tem ali é
oferta demanda. Que que elas fazem? Elas
ganham uma taxa em cima dessas apostas.
Então você se se tiver 93% das pessoas
votando sim e 7% votando não, elas vão
ganhar 94, tá? Você vai você vai pagar e
e vá e e contra oito. Ele vai ter uma
taxinha para você ganhar sempre um pouco
menos do que a OD. É isso que eles vão
ganhar. Por que que eles dizem que isso
é diferente? Porque não tem cassino.
Segundo eles não tem uma casa, eles
apenas regulam. Eles apenas regulam
apenas e cobram uma taxa em cima do
mercado daí que tá aí.
>> Meio de conexão, né, GR? É só o
intermediário, é só o atravessador. Eles
são exatamente onde que a gente já ouviu
essa desculpa antes, né?
>> Onde ele já ouviu essa desculpa antes,
né? Eles são o Uber, eles são o Rap,
eles são exatamente isso. A gente não
contrata motorista, a gente não é
cliente, a gente não é o fornecedor. A
gente só facilita
>> a conexão entre pessoas
>> se conhecerem.
>> E por que que a gente tá falando disso,
não é? Eh, por que que a gente tá
falando disso? Ah, só porque tem uma
nova bilionária brasileira? Não, não é
isso. É porque eh ela é um sintoma, ela
é uma parte, enfim. pequenos, um mercado
que não para de crescer, o mercado
talvez seja o mercado que mais cresceu
proporcionalmente esse ano. Afinal, a
própria Caus, tá? Só para ter uma ideia
do tamanho, ela tá com avaliação de 11
bilhões de sua terceira rodada de
captação só nesse ano, tá? É muita
coisa, não é? A C projeta fechar o ano
com 50 bilhões em volume negociado.
Falando 50 bilhões de dólares. Ano
passado, para você ter uma ideia, 300
milhões. Olha o quanto cresceu, não é?
Não sou, vou fazer a conta mais ou menos
de cabeça, mas cresceu quase 200 vezes
chutando aqui por alto. Eh, é, é, é um
crescimento realmente surreal, né? E é
algo que eu acho que é preciso ser dito,
é preciso, é preciso entender. E aqui o
o calmo urgente, a gente vai tentar
entender porque o que que isso significa
sobre o mundo hoje, né? E mais, dá para
chamar isso de mercado de previsões?
Fala Lê.
>> Eu queria dar botar esses 11 bilhões em
perspectiva, porque acho que para muita
gente isso pode parecer um pouco
abstrato, tá? Só para vocês terem uma
noção, por exemplo, a capitalização hoje
de mercado da Petrobras, ou seja, o
valuation da Petrobras hoje, quanto que
a empresa vale segundo o mercado? é
cerca de 77 bilhões de dólares. Então, a
gente tá falando de uma de uma startup,
de uma empresa que começou há
relativamente pouco tempo, que não tem
um produto de fato, que não vende nada
de materialmente relevante, que
simplesmente facilita a conexão entre
apostadores. Então eles são uma espécie
de mesa de pôker, entendeu? Aonde você
vem jogar o seu pôker. E essa grande
mesa de pôker vale hoje 11 biante de 77
bi de uma das maiores petrolheiras do
mundo. Então, só pra gente ter uma noção
de como, né, de como essas coisas se
comparam. É evidente que a Petrobras
vale mais, mas não é que ela vale nem 10
vezes mais. Eh, não são comparações
próximas demais, dadas diferenças de de
mercado mesmo entre essas duas coisas,
tá? E a gente pode depois buscar outras
comparações com outras empresas que
fazem coisas bem mais relevantes em
termos de valor pro mundo mesmo. A gente
pode discordar da Petrobras por vários
motivos em questão em em relação à
questão climática, por exemplo, mas é
innegável que ela tenha um produto muito
mais concreto e tangível do que a Cuche,
né? Então é uma é um é uma proporção
interessante da gente manter na cabeça
enquanto a gente avalia isso aqui e
conversa com vocês sobre a relevância
desse mercado.
>> Uhum. Por que mercado de previsão seria
problemático, Bruno, você veio com essa
crítica que eu acho que faz todo
sentido, né? Eu tô chamando aqui de
mercado de previsão. É um termo deles,
eles se intitulam assim, mas faz todo
sentido que a gente não aceite esse
termo, porque não se trata exatamente de
uma previsão, já que o que eles têm não
é, eles não são exatamente videntes, né?
Quem aposta lá tem muito mais a ver com
o quê? Com especulação, com aposta.
>> Então,
>> como é que você chamaria isso?
Então, Greg, eu eu acho assim, a gente
tem que ter muito senso crítico para não
adotar os termos que essas indústrias
nos oferecem, porque eles são os que
escolhem e como eles pensam isso, como
eles tem uma clareza muito grande do que
eles estão fazendo e pro resto do mundo
são coisas extremamente novas para as
quais nós não temos linguagem ainda,
meio que a gente aceita e divulga isso.
E assim, mercado de previsão é um jeito
meio idealizado de falar sobre esse tipo
de nós estamos especulando sobre algo
que vai acontecer. Então eu acho que vai
acontecer isso. Você acha que vai
acontecer é eh uma outra coisa a gente é
aposta. Mas se Mas se você for avaliar,
esse mercado altamente especulativo,
ele tá fazendo pressão e inferindo
coisas e fazendo investimentos pesados.
em coisas que fazem parte não do acaso,
não de algo que as pessoas não têm
ingerência, mas de coisas profundamente
humanas em que a decisão é humana, pesa
muito. Isso é uma dimensão, né? Outra
dimensão muito forte é a que é a visão
filosófica disso. Quando a Alessandra
coloca que eles estão crescendo muito
rápido, é muito vertiginoso. E você vê o
CEO deles, que é o sócio da brasileira
bilionária da Eluana. Esse cara deu uma
entrevista na semana passada, vale muito
a pena ver, em que ele fala qual é a
visão deles e a pessoa que tá
perguntando fala assim: "Ah, que de que
maneira você imagina que o seu mercado
vai eh atingir um eh trilhão de dólares,
que é o que eles especulam que vai eh
acontecer em tempo recorde, tá? E ele
fala: "A nossa intenção é financeirizar
todas as diferenças de opinião das
pessoas e é fazer com que aspa precisa
dele.
>> ASPA precisa dele. Anotei aqui, nós
queremos financeirizar todas as
diferenças de e opinião e fazer com que
elas virem em a produtos
comercializáveis em um tipo de bolsa,
em um é tradable eh asset, que é um
termo extremamente financeiro. Então, o
que eles estão fazendo, na verdade, não
é o mercado de previsão, na minha
opinião, é a financeirização
das nossas atividades
públicas, intelectuais e políticas de
decisões pessoais em níveis
assustadoramente específicos. Então,
para ter uma ideia, uma coisa é apostar
se o presidente vai ganhar a eleição ou
não. Isso é um assunto. Tem muitas
forças que implicam nisso e você pode
até falar que é difícil é corromper só
com o mercado de eh apostas um é
resultado tão alto é como esse. Mas eles
apostam em qual tema o presidente vai
fazer um discurso na sexta-feira,
qual alíquota de juros que uma agência
vai colocar, qual
o contratado de um certo lugar, qual vai
ser o primeiro demitido de uma equipe
pública, se a Taylor Swift vai ou não
engravidar no próximo ano, se alguém ou
não vai se separar. Então a gente não tá
falando só de política, o que a gente
tava falando é de uma invasão
econômica e financeira.
dos assuntos mais prosaicos, humanos,
públicos e assim, e vocês conseguem
imaginar o tipo de corrupção que isso
pode implicar. Não tô falando de uma
corrupção é convencional, né, de você
rouba, mas eu acho que é um mercado não
só especulativo, mas de um potencial é
manipulativo, gigantesco e que pega uma
sociedade que já é muito polarizada, é,
politicamente por investimento emocional
e você bota grana nisso.
você cria uma polarização financeira em
uma série de coisas e você pode imaginar
o tipo de peso que muita grana, que
mídia, que manipulação de narrativa, que
uso de rede social e que a fusão com
outras empresas do mesmo mercado digital
que já fazem extremas manipulações de
hábitos, de opiniões, de polarização.
Quando você enfia no meio de rede
social, de excesso de informação e de
mídia, você bota uma camada de é aposta
nisso tudo. Então essa é a distopia que
tá sendo, é criada e é vertiginosamente
bem é suucedida.
>> É, teve uma entrevista que a própria
Luana Lara deu agora para exame depois
da repercussão, que foi uma repercussão
gigante, né, da da do anúncio dessa
brasileira muito jovem. que ao que tudo
indica pela história de vida, pelas
coisas que ela fez, por onde ela estudou
e pelo próprio fato de ter criado a
empresa, parece ser uma pessoa brilhante
em muitos sentidos, que é parte também
do que me entristece na história, né?
saber que a gente tá com os melhores
cérebros do mundo, claramente pessoas
com muito potencial para fazer
contribuições gigantes paraa humanidade,
capturados nessa lógica de criar modelos
predatórios de eh de base de de de
concentração de valor a partir de nada,
de coisas que têm muito pouco impacto
positivo no mundo, né? Então, não duvido
que seja uma pessoa brilhante, realmente
parece ser e a parte da da tristeza, mas
enfim. Mas depois dessa repercussão
gigante, a Luana deu uma
entrevista para exame, eh, que eu também
achei bastante iluminadora, né? Primeiro
que a primeira coisa que ela fala é:
"Não somos uma casa de apostas". Eh, e a
gente vai, inclusive no ano que vem no
nosso clube de cultura, um dos livros
que a gente pretende ler é o Don Cavan
Elephant, que vai ser traduzido em
português pela primeira vez, eh, e que
cujo título é: "Em português, não pensem
em um elefante." E, e toda a tese do
Lacof, do autor desse livro, que a gente
já mencionou aqui no Calma algumas
vezes, é que quando você precisa falar,
"Eu não sou um elefante", a única coisa
que tá todo mundo pensando é no
elefante. Então, se você se você é
obrigado a dizer que você não é um
elefante, é, você já perdeu a conversa
pública. Porque se eu falo: "Não pensa
num elefante", você imediatamente pensa
num elefante. E o fato dessa empresa
precisar o tempo todo justificar que ela
não é uma bet já é muito iluminador de
quão próximo o modelo da empresa é de
uma bet. Inclusive, o que a gente sabe
sobre a trajetória da empresa é que
demorou muito tempo para ela conseguir
atuar legalmente nos Estados Unidos,
justamente porque as autoridades
entendiam que era um modelo muito
parecido com o debet. Eh, e ela só
conseguiu sua licença para operar depois
que ela, né, caiu nas graças de um
advogado específico com bastante acesso
a certas autoridades. E depois que ela
colocou
>> o filho do presidente, o Donald Júnior,
no seu eh conselho, né? As duas algo, eu
acho que isso é algo muito importante.
>> O Polymarket e a C.
>> Isso. O Donald Trump Júnior tá no
conselho das duas empresas, o filho do
Donald Trump. Então ela pode ser uma
selfmade billionaire. Ela contratou
pessoas que não são exatamente selfmade
billioniros, não, tá? Ela tem assim, ela
tem gente, enfim, bastante influente lá
dentro para regularizar a casa de
apostas. E como a Alessandra bem falou,
quando alguém diz que não é uma casa, se
você não vê o hospital eh
Círio Libanês dizendo que não é uma casa
de apostas, você não vê o cursinho
pré-vestibular [risadas] da favela
dizendo: "Não somos uma casa de
apostas". Você só vê a casa de apostas
falando isso? É um pouco como o esquema
de pirâmide. Nunca nenhum bom negócio
foi apresentado como não é um esquema de
pirâmide. Nunca. Mas olha, [risadas]
>> a pessoa que precisa explicar isso. Só o
esquema de pirâmide diz que não é um
esquema de pirâmide, mas fala.
>> Eu quero fazer só um comentário rápido
em defesa das casas de aposta, porque eu
acho que eles não são mesmo, eles podem
ser algo um pouco pior do que a casa de
aposta,
>> porque a casa de aposta, assim como um
cassino físico, é esclarecedor. Você
entende onde você tá entrando. Eu estou
entrando no mercado de aposta. Eu sei
que isso aqui vicia. Eu sei que isso
aqui a a casa sempre ganha. Eu sei, isso
tem um histórico, tem tipo patologias
muito bem descritas disso. É tipo assim,
isso é um bordel, você sabe onde você tá
indo, não vem fingir que não, mas fala,
isso não é bem um é bordel, é o fatal
model, entendeu? É uma coisa no fim das
contas pior, é meio parecido com Uber,
com uma tipo precarização, porque eles
ficam ilesos do mínimo de consequências
que eles deveriam ter caso fossem uma
devida casa de eh aposta. E eles se
arvoram como algo mais perigoso, que não
é nós somos inocentes aqui, estamos
fazendo só a apresentação. Não, porque
uma coisa que aqui no Brasil a gente
prestou muita atenção nisso por conta da
nossa primeira bilionária selfe. Mas lá
fora, a coisa que chamou a atenção
mesmo, que foi que foi um motivo pelo
qual é muita gente ficou assustado, foi
que eles estão fazendo parcerias agora
de fusão com a CNN,
>> tá? de incluir no noticiário
apostas e as previsões que o público da
CNN vai fazer em relação às próprias
notícias. Eles têm apostas lá de tipo
assim que tipo de coisa o Anderson
Cooper vai falar no próximo bloco,
entendeu? Então assim, o que eu acho que
eles estão fazendo que é pior do que
casa de aposta é fazendo com que a vida
vire uma casa de eh aposta, entendeu? e
não um lugar isolado ou onde nós vamos
apostar o nosso dinheiro, mas é fazer
com que o jornalismo, com que as
opiniões, com que as eleições, com que a
gravidez de uma celebridade vire parte
do que eles chamam de mercado.
>> Perfeito. Eh, o pessoal que regula e que
fala disso, né, em inglês tem o National
Councilor of Problem Gambling, [risadas]
é o pessoal que cuida do National
Council of Problem Gambling. Gamblin,
>> o Conselho Nacional de Aposta
Problemática.
>> Exatamente. É isso.
>> Já disse que, enfim, é para eles
exatamente a mesma coisa. Eles tem um
termo que é ludopatia, que é o vício em
em jogos, é o vício em apostas. Eh,
cerebralmente neurologicamente é
exatamente a mesma coisa. apostar em
futuros ou apostar em futebol, que
também é futuro, mas não é diferente. Ou
apostar e no black jack ou apostar no
cassino, no titing, no gassanques, é a
mesma coisa neurologicamente atinge
exatamente o mesmo vício. Mas o Bruno
falou uma coisa que é verdade. Quando
eles dizem que não é sobre apostas,
ã, é sobre a verdade, é o que mais me
apavora também, porque essa é a tese
deles, né? O que eles estão tentando
vender é que aquilo ali, que olha só a
frase da, essa frase é do Coplin, que é
o fundador da Poly Market, Shane Coplan,
>> que é a que é a concorrência da CCH, né?
Tá exatamente no mesmo mercado. É.
>> Uhum. O que realmente estamos tentando
construir é algo que seja um farol da
verdade.
Porque o que eles acham, o que eles
acham ou fingem que acham, é que ali
você vai ter uma, por causa do livre
mercado, com muitas aspas, pelo amor de
Deus, de informação, você vai ter algo
muito mais próximo do futuro, do que vai
acontecer, porque você, as pessoas, elas
vão estar não reguladamente dizendo o
que elas acham. Ou seja, tem uma crença
ali que é uma crença, na verdade pré,
sei lá, platônica, desculpa se tiver
falando besteira, mas é a ideia meio de
que a verdade não existe, sabe? E de que
o que existe mesmo verdadeiro aquilo que
convence, aquela coisa, né, sofística
mesmo assim de que não existe verdade do
O que existe é um discurso eficaz. Você
tem que conseguir convencer as pessoas
eh de que aquilo é verdade. Então, se
aquilo ele tá ganhando, é porque é
verdade. Então, é realmente uma
distopeira. estão dizendo que eles são
um farol da verdade, mas eles são um
cemitério da verdade, né? Eles são eh a
ideia de que
>> a verdade realmente não existe. O
jornalismo comprar essa e começar a
vincular as notícias à ideia de que
aquilo ali pode ser verdadeiro porque tá
todo mundo apostando.
Sem sem lembrar, sem entender que aquilo
ali, quem tá apostando às vezes tá
apostando a tem mais dinheiro. Ou seja,
é no mínimo a verdade dita pelo
dinheiro, né? O máximo que aquilo ali
ele pode dizer é onde é que tá o
dinheiro, quem tem mais dinheiro para
botar, onde. Então você pode, por
exemplo, criar as famosas profecias
autorrealizadas o tempo todo, que são
profecias que acontecem porque você as
faz. E é algo que no mercado existe o
tempo todo, né? ali talvez possa falar
um pouco melhor, mas eu acho que o Kanes
tinha aquela ideia, não é, de que não,
agora vou falar uma besteira aqui,
certamente porque eu vou estar
parafraseando, acho que na economia eh é
um concurso de beleza, a economia no
qual vence aquela que mais pessoas votam
achando que vai ganhar, não é? [risadas]
Ele tem ele tem alguma palavra, ele tem
alguma ideia nesse coisa aí. A gente
pode, a gente pedir, pode pedir pra Luía
que tá acompanhando a nossa gravação,
fazer a checagem dessa de quem certeza
essa ideia de o Gregório tá certo ou o
Gregório tá errado.
>> Exatamente.
>> Mas sim, mas essa ideia, essa confusão
entre as metodologias, né? Eu acho que
tem uma coisa aqui que é muito central e
e eu queria voltar pra entrevista da
Luana já, porque tem coisas ali
interessantes, mas só para ficar na no
tema que vocês trouxeram, por que que é
especialmente complicado quando a gente
começa a confundir justamente um grande
mercado de apostas, né, sobre o futuro
com a busca da verdade? E por que que é
especialmente preocupante quando uma
empresa como a CNN, que trabalha com
jornalismo, começa a se unir ou se aliar
a esse tipo de mercado, eh, dado o fato
de que uma empresa é jornalística,
porque a gente começa a confundir
metodologia. o que essa o que esse
mercado faz essencialmente e a e a
afirmação de que ele estaria eh
basicamente ajudando a gente a entender
a verdade é que ele vai agregar as
apostas de muita gente. Então a defesa
que se faz dele como um instrumento de
averiguação de quase que de
probabilidade de alguma coisa acontecer
é basicamente a seguinte, é meio a mão
invisível do mercado, né? É, olha,
quando você tem milhares de pessoas
colocando dinheiro numa numa
possibilidade, você presume que todas
essas pessoas fizeram pesquisa, se
informaram, procuraram entender a chance
daquilo acontecer e que essa sabedoria
coletiva que vem de muita gente, ela vai
ter mais chances de de fato apontar para
paraa probabilidade mais correta do que
outras metodologias. É isso que tá
implícito, né? Então, o quais são as
outras metodologias de previsão de um
resultado ou de um evento futuro? A
gente tem um método científico. Então,
quando a gente fala sobre mudança
climática, por exemplo, né, a Caus tem
perguntas sobre a mudança climática. Aí
você poderia dizer: "Bom, você tem ali
um monte de gente fazendo a sua própria
pesquisa eh apostando num num evento
futuro relacionado à mudança climática
ou você tem a comunidade científica
usando a metodologia científica para
chegar nessa mesma eh nessa mesma
conclusão, enfim, nesse mesmo cálculo
probabilístico." Ou você poderia ter uma
metodologia que não é exatamente
científica, mas é a metodologia da
apuração jornalística, que envolve
provavelmente você falar com os
cientistas, você averiguar junto com
fontes, você entender que em que em que
outras estruturas de influência esses
cientistas estão inseridos. Então, o
interesse da metodologia jornalística,
ela não é científica exatamente, mas ela
tem uma coisa muito bonita que eu acho
que a gente tá perdendo nesse mundo em
que o jornalismo tá morrendo, que é essa
capacidade de, né, no no melhor
jornalismo, de averiguar não só aquilo
que as autoridades, no caso, os
cientistas, né, no caso de mudança
climática, tão dizendo que vai
acontecer, mas entrar também no contexto
no qual essas autoridades se inserem.
Então, esse jornalista, esse, perdão,
esse cientista que tá me dizendo que
mudança climática é um engodo, que isso
não vai acontecer, quem paga a conta
desse cara, aonde que o departamento
acadêmico, onde ele tá inserido, onde é
que esse departamento vai se financiar,
eh, que outras relações ele tem na vida
dele. Então, o jornalismo, ele tem essa
capacidade de fazer esse tipo de
averiguação. Isso é um método e ele é um
método totalmente diferente do método de
simplesmente agregação de opiniões
supostamente bem informadas, tá? Isso
quer dizer que a opinião das pessoas não
tenha um valor? Que saber a opinião das
pessoas não tenha valor? É evidente que
não. Tanto que a gente tem pesquisa de
opinião. O que eles estão basicamente
dizendo aqui é a pesquisa de opinião,
ela simplesmente diz o que você acha,
mas não tem custo para você emitir a sua
opinião. A partir do momento que você tá
botando dinheiro na sua opinião, eu
pressuponho que você fez um trabalho de
se informar mais. Mas é evidente que
isso não quer dizer muita coisa, porque
manipulação de massa é a coisa mais
velha do mundo. Essa sim é
pré-platônica, entendeu? A coisa mais
fácil do mundo é você convencer muita
gente de uma coisa que é rigorosamente
falsa. O problema aqui é se você começa
justamente fazer as pessoas colocarem o
rico dinheirinho delas ancorado nessas
previsões mal, muitas vezes mal feitas
ou mal informadas pela enorme maioria
das pessoas. E pior, se você começa a
fazer elas fazerem isso, eh, acerca de
coisas que, como o Bruno disse, podem
ser facilmente controladas por um grupo,
ou seja, não é mudança climática, mas é
quantas vezes o Donald Trump vai falar a
palavra enemies no próximo discurso que
ele pode decidir simplesmente. Então,
quando você começa a fazer isso, você
corre o risco de fazer com que uma parte
significativa da sociedade deposite
valor numa coisa que pode absoluta, que
é absolutamente especulativa e que pode
se esfarcelar amanhã. E aí você começa a
criar muito incentivo para essa coisa
não espaçar amanhã, né? Então, se você
tem muito valor ancorado ali, muita
gente, por exemplo, dizendo que,
sei lá, que o Donald Trump vai ganhar a
eleição e aí de repente parece que ele
não vai ganhar, o que que isso quer
dizer em termos de consequências
financeiras para essas pessoas e,
portanto, pra sociedade mesmo? Então, é
um modelo que se ele cresce mais e se
ele se torna muito massificado, ele leva
e ele aprofunda um problema que a gente
já tem no mercado financeiro, que é esse
custo muito grande pra sociedade das
falhas dessas previsões, né? Hoje, se
você tem um fundo de pensão que tá ali,
por exemplo, investindo, vamos pegar o
caso do Rio de Janeiro, né? Você tem ali
o fundo de pensão dos servidores do Rio
de Janeiro botando dinheiro no Banco
Master.
>> O que que esse fundo de pensão tá
fazendo? Ele tá falando que o Banco
Master vai eh a a aposta dos operadores
do fundo de pensão é o Banco Master vai
prosperar e vai pagar todos esses, né,
todos vai pagar todos esses dividendos e
e apostar nesses instrumentos
financeiros faz sentido porque eles são
saudáveis e vão dar o retorno que eles
estão prometendo. Quando o fundo de
pensão erra numa previsão assim, você
tem eventualmente bilhões de reais de
dinheiro dos servidores públicos que se
evapora de uma hora para outra. Mas você
ainda tá fazendo isso dentro de um
mercado altamente regulado, com várias,
né? E mesmo assim você tem esses
desastres. Agora, o que a C ou Polyarket
proponham é que pessoas comuns possam
apostar as suas economias, a sua
aposentadoria, a sua grana, não num
fundo de pensão que eventualmente vai
comprar ações do Banco Master ou vai
comprar títulos emitidos pelo Banco
Master, mas diretamente na possibilidade
do Banco Master falir ou não. E nessa
nessa aposta e se isso de repente se
concretiza ou não se concretiza, isso
também tem um impacto na economia e na
vida das pessoas. E aí que eu acho que
tem grandes problemas mesmo. É, mas eu
acho que você definiu muitíssimo bem e
eu acho que você ainda tá até um pouco
idealista mesmo assim que eu sei que
você não é e eu sei que você sabe que o
problema é muito gigantesco, mas assim,
acho que tem uma coisa até anterior a
isso que é assim,
mercado de aferição de É verdade, seja
ela científica ou jornalística, em geral
tem a ver com fatos objetivos e fatos
consumados e não coisas que não que não
aconteceram ainda. Isso é uma coisa
super importante. Mas mesmo coisas de
previsão, de cassino, de eh aposta e
mesmo na bolsa de valores, como a
Alessandra colocou, tem um mercado não
só extremamente regulado, mas bastante
limitado, com regras muito muito claras
do uso de informação é privilegiada. No
caso do mercado financeiro, que é uma
das que é um dos maiores crimes que você
pode cometer, que quer dizer você usa
uma informação uma privilegiada para eh
para você ganhar
eh grana de maneira desonesta ou no
cassino, em que a coisa mais importante
é que o dado não seja viciado, que não
tenha um íã na sua roleta. Mas o que
eles estão anunciando, que eles estão
fazendo no fundo, é espalhando o
ecassino para o mundo todo, onde por
definição, todo mundo tem informação
privilegiada de alguma coisa e todo
mundo tem como viciar algum tipo de
dada. Isso é uma coisa e outra que é nem
todo mundo vai entrar nesse mercado para
apostar.
Uma grande parte da grana que esses
caras contam que vai entrar nas suas
plataformas é gente que tá disposta a
perder grana. Mas para fazer com que o
seu interesse lhe pareça mais relevante
do que ele de fato é. Então, candidatos
podem enfiar muita grana no polymket ou
no C para parecer que ele tem 20% de
chance de ganhar uma eleição. E aí a
imprensa que já tá em parceria com isso
percebe isso, o público que tá ali e ele
se torna pauta meio quase que aqui que é
comprando espaço. E para terminar, uma
coisa que a gente esquece, dinheiro de
aposta é o dinheiro que historicamente
ele é corruptor em vários níveis, no
viciado, mas especialmente na na
dinâmica em si, no apostado em si. Nós
vemos o o o efeito bizarro que isso
provoca em esporte, as máfias, futebol e
tudo mais,
>> mas imagina isso em coisas que não são
tão consequentes quanto o futebol. E aí
que a coisa tá entrando de maneira,
>> é porque o futebol, pelo menos, no
futebol, eu não tô defendendo o Bet não,
a gente, todo mundo sabe que a gente é
contra e fez um programa inteiro sobre
isso, mas no futebol não altera em nada,
a princípio, o fato de tá todo mundo
achando que o Flamengo vai ganhar. O
Flamengo não vai jogar melhor para
ganhar, para Sãois, a não ser, claro, no
caso específico, o jogador fica fazendo
falta para ganhar um cartão amarelo, é
um jogador específico, ele não consegue,
por exemplo, ganhar o jogo para ganhar
mais dinheiro depois. Enfim, é, o
futebol não é tão direto, facilmente
afetado, eu acho, ah, pela pelas
apostas. você realmente teve teve
algumas tentativas e e atrapalhou o
futebol, mas ele é objetivamente mais
difícil de você eh, por exemplo, marcar
um gol. Se fosse tão fácil, as pessoas
marcavam sete gols e tudo, né? É mais
difícil você alterar porque você precisa
jogar muito bem ou muito mal e tal.
Agora, a política é precisamente aquilo
em que a previsão afeta o fato, porque
percepção de poder na política equivale
a poder.
>> Então, um candidato que começa a crescer
nas apostas, ele vai crescer também na
cobertura midiática, logo ele vai
crescer também no próprio voto. Então, a
profecia se autorealiza o tempo todo. E
eu fico curioso para saber, por exemplo,
se a polícia não tem que ficar em cima,
porque eu acho que os seria interessante
se fosse algo do governo para entender
assim: "Olha só, alguém aqui acabou de
botar 1 milhão de dólares que o sar que
vai ter um um boom de sarampo nos
Estados Unidos. Vai na casa essa pessoa
agora, prende porque ela tá sabendo
alguma coisa que ela não tá contando,
tá, em relação a sarampo que pode salvar
a vida de 1 milhão de pessoas". Então
assim, se tem alguém botando dinheiro em
qualquer coisa, 1 milhão que seja, que o
mandame vai ser deportado, um dinheiro
que importa, ou esse cara tá sabendo
demais
e não tá contando, ou a informação
privilegiada,
ou é uma tentativa de manipulação. Ele
quer que pareça que o Mandame vai ser
deportado, que também deveria ser crime.
Então, ou ele tá perdendo dinheiro para
manipular politicamente, ou ele sabe
mais do que deveria e tá ganhando
dinheiro em cima de uma informação
privilegiada. Não tem opção limpa para
quem tá ganhando dinheiro com isso.
>> Então, independente disso, cara, que eu
e assim, só um parêntese rápido, o filho
do presidente que pode tentar deportar
>> tá no conselho das duas empresas. Então,
assim, e tá ganhando e tá ganhando
dinheiro com criptomoeda, que é a moeda
preferida do Polyarket, onde circula
cripto. Então, assim, possibilidade de
lavar, toda uma categoria, é uma
categoria de apostas, né,
>> uma categoria de aposta, é uma categoria
de aposta gigantesca. Então é isso que
eu falo assim, uma é, eu acho que ele é
um, ele é uma dimensão muito distópica
da pós é verdade e os caras se arvoram
para eh falar disso, mas eu coloco foi
financierização também. É, mas eu coloco
eles numa categoria eh mais ampla, que é
desses demônios da distopia digital que
a gente tá vivendo já há uns bons 15
anos. Eu acho que eles são o novo ciclo
do inferno. Mas assim, se você for
escutar o que o Marque Zuckerg, o que o
dono do Twitter falava, o que o Elomask
falava, o que o Google falava há 15
anos, é muito parecido com o que o
Paulin Market fala, que é essa utopia
das multidões digitais, uma utopia que a
gente já tem que estar completamente
vacinado de que ela não funciona, mas
assim que é vamos democratizar o acesso
às apostas e disso a gente vai emergir
uma verdade mais refinada. Falava-se
isso de rede social, gente. Vamos
incluir bilhões de pessoas no nosso
algoritmo
>> e essa e e disso a gente vai aferir um
jornalismo cada vez mais afiado. A gente
vê as realidad, a gente vê a corrupção.
E o que
>> realmente a caixa de comentários eh
melhorou muito o jornalismo, né?
>> É,
>> sempre você vai na caixa de comentários,
você vai ver que a ele ele complementa a
matéria com informações que não tinha. A
caixa de comentários é a prova de que
realmente o a muda. É muito bom mesmo
você ter a opinião do leitor misturada.
matéria,
>> mas sem jogar fora o poder das
multidões, que eu, como democrata e
socialista acredito que a gente tem
realmente sabedoria na multidão, não é
nos termos de pessoas que têm a intenção
de virarem trilionários literalmente.
Em geral, o poder da produção é
democrática vem de pessoas
desinteressadas financeiramente no
resultado econômico disso, mas sim no
resultado democrático em si. A prova
disso é que com todos os defeitos a a é
Wikipedia é muito melhor do que o
Twitter porque ela não é um mercado de
ganhar dinheiro ali. Você não, o
interesse lá é de produção de
conhecimento coletivo com todas as
imperfeições e as possíveis
manipulações, mas não se compara com
Facebook, com o Twitter e com nada
disso. E tá se criando uma nova camada
com essa mesma promessa tecnout utopista
patética. E o que mais me deprime nem a
possibilidade de manipulação aqui e ali
que vai acontecer no atacado, mas é uma
coisa um pouco mais profunda e mais
cínica, que é uma capitulação da eh
sociedade a esse a a essa ética da Bet,
a esse mundo em que a gente já não tem
mais idealismo, que tudo é vendido mesmo
e que as nossas opiniões são um mercado.
Uhum.
E essas pessoas elas t celebradas e não
perseguidas mesmo como vilões culturais
que eu acho que são. E para terminar
assim, uma coisa que a gente perdeu a
capacidade de se questionar mesmo. A
gente só avalia bilhão e mercado e o
número e quantas pessoas entram assim.
Existe algum jeito disso fazer o mundo
minimamente melhor? Claramente não.
Assim, é é tipo a criação de um novo
cenário de distopia, de risco alto para
muito pouca gente ficar muitíssimo rica,
>> cara. E aqui eu vou fazer uma conexão
com uma série que eu não sei se vocês
estão vendo que é Pluribus. Vocês viram?
A gente não falou disso, né?
>> Eu vi, eu vi.
>> Fala aqui de improviso.
>> Eu vi. Para mim é uma série sobre essa
ideia de que a inteligência
coletiva é melhor. O que a gente precisa
é criar a inteligência artificial,
enfim, a ideia de que você tem que unir
>> os saberes do mundo e criar uma
inteligência divina, sabe? Que vai ser o
farol da verdade. A catastro, sabe? A
distopia do farol da verdade. [ __ ]
que que série desesperadora e
maravilhosa. Recomendo muito que todos
vejam. Não vamos dar spoiler aqui, não.
Vamos falar mais. Vamos falar certamente
no clube do livro do da de cultura do
Calm Urgente no ano que vem.
>> Uma boa série pra gente discutir,
diga-se.
>> Mas não tem a ver, cara. Para mim tem
muito a ver com isso. Mas diga,
Alessandro.
>> Eu queria não, eu queria voltar em
alguns pontos que vocês trouxeram que
acho que vale a gente aprofundar. A a
aspa da entrevista da Luana para exame
que eu queria trazer é a seguinte. Bom,
primeiro ela abre falando que ela não é
uma bet e aí depois o momento elefante,
o momento não pensa num elefante e
depois ela fala o seguinte: "Acreditamos
que a gente ainda vai crescer muito mais
e ter algo muito mais amplo do que o
mercado de ações. Isso porque com
qualquer pergunta ou divergência de
opinião pode-se construir um mercado. Os
dados extraídos a partir disso também
são valiosos. Quem está colocando
dinheiro pesquisou. Então, o resultado
serve como uma informação do que vai
acontecer no futuro. Eu acho eh muito
muito muito reveladora essa resposta da
dela para exame. Uma entrevista, aliás,
péssima, tá? A entrevista em si, um
trabalho completamente superficial. Isso
não tem nenhum, não tem pergunta sobre a
presença do Donald Trump Júnior no bord
da empresa, não tem nenhum
questionamento mais duro. É, é parte
dessa cultura da celebração do
bilionário simplesmente por ter bilhões
de dólares, que parece ter permeado não
só as redes sociais, mas também a
imprensa, mas também a própria política,
né? da figura do bilionário como a
liderança perfeita, que eu acho e é é um
assunto em si que a gente pode já
abordar, mas eu queria ficar nessa aspa
dela. essa ideia de que as nossas
divergências de opinião podem virar um
mercado que é muito central na na
no modelo de negócios, é a centralidade
do modelo de negócios, me preocupa
especialmente porque divergências de
opinião são a a matéria prima viva da
democracia. É em cima das nossas
divergências de opinião que a gente
discute democraticamente sobre aquilo
que um país, uma nação, uma comunidade,
uma cidade, um bairro deveria ou não
fazer. Então, financeirizar, ancorar,
né, resultados financeiros nas nossas
diferenças de opinião, vai criar uma
distorção. Qual vai ser a distorção?
Qual o nível de profundidade dessa
distorção? Como que isso afeta a tomada
de decisão dos diferentes agentes em
imposição de poder, sobretudo quando
você tem esse tipo de conflito de
interesse? Óbvio, por exemplo, a
presença do Donald Trump Júnior no
conselho da empresa que tá ali tentando
criar um mercado a partir das diferenças
de opinião. Eh, qual a gente não sabe
ainda, a gente não sabe todas as
distorsões, a gente vai descobrir, mas é
mais uma dessas coisas em que o fato de
que haverá distorões é evidente.
qualquer criança consegue entender isso.
E a gente tá permitindo que isso invada
as nossas vidas e comece a ter impactos
reais na sociedade sem ter tido nenhum
tipo de discussão sobre essas
distorções. Então, o nível de presunção
da Luana nessa entrevista de chegar e
falar: "Não, isso a gente tá fazendo,
vai ser um mercado é maravilhoso e não
em nenhum momento ter um mínimo de
questionamento sobre o impacto que isso
tem no mundo, me preocupa. E como eu
falei antes, que eu acho que ela
provavelmente, eu não conheço a pessoa,
mas tudo indica que é uma pessoa
brilhante, capaz, com muit muito
inteligente, eu fico também me
perguntando e e e refletindo um pouco
sobre a falta que faz uma formação em
humanas, sabe? Alguém que foi direto
para uma formação em exatas, que foi
olhar para número. E como a gente
precisa ter discussões mais qualificadas
sobre modelo mesmo de democracia, sabe?
porque me parece que isso escapa para
muita gente. Então isso é um ponto. O
outro ponto que eu queria voltar antes
da gente ir adiante é sobre esses
objetos das apostas, né? A gente falou
de como os objetos podem ser, por
exemplo, eleições ou resultados, né? ou
ou eventos sobre as quais pessoas têm
muita ingerência, como isso pode ser
corrompido ou corromper o próprio
resultado eleitoral ou a próprio
processo democrático e assim por diante.
Mas tem um outro aspecto dessa história
que me assusta demais e que também me
parece pouquíssimo explorado na
cobertura de imprensa, que são os
aspectos mais pessoais para as pessoas
que são objetos de aposta. Então, por
exemplo, você poder apostar dinheiro em
se a Taylor Swift vai ou não engravidar
ano que vem, né? Para além do fato de
que a própria Taylor Swift poderia
apostar dinheiro, e aí eu acho que ela
talvez esteja em posição de ganhar. Eh,
tem também uma questão aí que é, imagina
que a Taylor Swift quer muito engravidar
ano que vem e que ela perde o neném. Ela
engravida, mas ela perde o bebê no
primeiro mês de gestação, como tantas
mulheres já passaram por isso. E aí tem
gente na internet apostando dinheiro num
evento que é talvez a coisa mais pessoal
e íntima que uma pessoa pode ter,
entende? Enquanto ela tá lidando com
isso na vida dela, tem gente ganhando e
ganhando dinheiro em cima disso, que é
uma coisa tão pessoal dela. Ou alguém
apostar dinheiro na demissão de alguém,
coisa que está acontecendo nesse exato
momento no polymarket na CCH. Pessoas
que trabalham pro governo federal e você
tem aposta do tipo fulano, vai ser
demitido até fevereiro. Isso para quem
tá apostando é um jogo. Ah, vai ser
demitido, não vai ser demitido. Para
quem é o objeto da aposta, isso é uma
distorção sem limites, porque você passa
a ter incentivos financeiros para alguém
te demitir potencialmente. O seu chefe,
inclusive, pode ser quem tá apostando
que você será demitido e você não tem
como saber.
Então é um nível de loucura em que a
gente tá fazendo com que seres humanos
comuns, porque nesse aspecto Taylor
Sutch é a pessoa pública, tem um tanto
de escrutínio público na vida dela que é
parte da parada, entendeu? É parte dessa
escolha de ser uma grande celebridade. E
e eu entendo que a gente tem que a gente
não pode avaliar o nível de invasão de
privacidade que existe na vida da Taylor
Swift e comparar isso com a da
Mariazinha da esquina. Mas até grandes
celebridades e e sobretudo também
funcionários públicos que não são
grandes celebridades e outras pessoas
merecem um nível de privacidade, de
controle sobre suas próprias vidas. E a
gente admitir que exista um mercado e
celebrar isso como uma coisa muito
legal, aonde essas pessoas são objetos
dos interesses mais mesquinhos e
perversos de uma multidão anônima que
pode ficar ganhando dinheiro com as suas
próprias desgraças pessoais, os seus
sofrimentos, as suas dificuldades na
vida. Isso é de um nível de imoralidade
que eu não consigo nem definir. Eu acho
assim o fundo do poço.
>> Assim, eu acho que tem coisas que são é
imorais meio a tipo é meio autoevidente,
né? A gente não tem muito o que dizer. E
acho que isso é talvez a coisa mais
relevante dessa pauta, que não é a
análise do mercado em si que tá
emergindo como uma grande força, mas é é
mais um passo na direção de um certo
abismo cultural do capitalismo é tardio,
né? A gente já falou num outro calma
urgente da cultura do vendido, né? A
gente fez um bom programa disso, né? De
que falta na verdade uma certa vergonha
na cara que a gente perdeu como
sociedade, tanto de eh artistas, mas de
indivíduos mesmo, né? que a gente não, a
gente a gente tinha uma dimensão muito
clara eh culturalmente de um artista,
uma pessoa pública que era admirado, que
tinha uma produção cultural, que era um
músico especialmente e que se vendia
para alguma marca ou fazia alguma
parceria e tinha um preço muito alto
para se pagar. E acho que se tem um
fenômeno que tem acontecido muito muito
é nos últimos anos e a cultura de e é
bilionário de tecnologia representa
muito isso, que não é necessariamente a
financeiriação de tudo, que é o que eles
vendem, né? Eles falam isso abertamente,
mas é a mas é a ideia de que nada é
sagrado mesmo, de que tudo é só grana.
>> E de e e de que você soa quase que
moralista, você soa quase que é
conservador se você acha que isso é
inadmissível, que ninguém tem o direito
de apostar na vida de outras pessoas. e
fazendo uma defesa da Tilwift mesmo. Eu
acho que no caso de tipo eu sei que
gente muito famosa, gente pública e tudo
mais, meio que perde um certo direito a
é privacidade
pela própria escala da sua fama. Mas
acho que no caso de aposta tem algo que
se inverte. Eu acho que é meio mais
cruel com quem é famoso exatamente pelo
volume de grana que isso pode implicar,
porque a aposta em gente muito pública
vira algo tão grande em que a pessoa se
sente mais se sente pessoalmente ainda
mais violada na sua carreira ou ou em
ter filho ou em terminar um casamento,
né? Coisas assim. E então acho que tem
algo meio, é até estranho falar isso,
mas é meio demoníaco mesmo assim, né?
entrando nessas áreas. E aí quando eu vi
a aspa que a Alessandra destacou da
nossa selfem madeade bilionária, eu
falei: "Nossa, ela tem vocação de
bilionária mesmo. Antes de ser
bilionária, ela já tem essa pretensão
antidemocrática que o bilionário ou é
contemporâneo selfemade precisa ter
mesmo. E essa pessoa meio herói da Ian
Rand, que a pessoa acha que que sozinha,
tendo a ideia certa e chamando o cara
certo para o conselho da empresa dela,
se associando com o filho do presidente
fascista dos Estados Unidos ou achando o
sócio do EMIT, que é o outro gênio que
sabe programar, essas pessoas têm o eh
direito ou até a obrigação
de incidir sobre o destino das eh
sociedades.
Essas são perguntas que não nos fazem
mais. A gente quer viver em um regime
que a nossa vida é objeto de aposta, sim
ou não? A gente não vota mais nisso. E a
criação dessa super estrutura digital e
trilionária agora, porque agora a gente
não fala mais de bilionário, né? a gente
fala de trilionários, que é a
expectativa que essa empresa vai se
tornar em um, dois anos, que eles estão
falando isso abertamente. Não, mas eles
estão falando mas não vai, mas nós não
vamos comprar porque isso também é
especulativo.
>> Claro que seja, mas assim, a gente tá
falando de 100 bilhões já de assim o
mercado de previsão no ano passado,
aliás, desculpa, esse ano, esse ano, o
mercado desse ano,
>> ele movimentou 100 bilhões de dólares.
já é mais que a Petrobras vale, né?
Então assim, e a gente tá falando disso.
Então assim, a chance disso escalar
muito rápido, independente se vai ser
tri ou 500 BI, o ponto não é esse. O
ponto é esse volume de dinheiro dentro
da e política, mas a mas a criação de
uma superestrutura digital que a
política não tem nem condição de eh
legislar, porque eles nem sabem falar
disso, eles estão criando uma nova
sociedade meio que sobreposta na é nossa
em que a gente não tem incidência. Então
assim, vocês imaginam o nosso Congresso
debatendo o mercado de previsão? Não, os
caras não conseguir, eu não imagino ele
debatendo, mas eu perfeitamente imagino
o nosso congresso usando o mercado de
previsão para manipular e ganhar
dinheiro, porque exatamente é a cara do
nosso congresso.
>> Aí eles são perfeitamente copante.
>> Exatamente.
>> Claro. Se vocês viram o que aconteceu,
você que é flamenguista, viu o que
aconteceu com Lucas Paquetá jogando ali,
[risadas] apostando que você, não sei se
lembra desse caso, né, que a ilha de ele
chama Lucas Paquetá. A ilha inteira de
Paquetá, que é uma ilha no Rio de
Janeiro, apostou que ele ia ganhar
cartão amarelo. A ilha inteira de
Paquetax, a família dele, os amigos
todos deles. [risadas] E tipo, imagina
isso, que que não vai ser com os doutor
Alfredinho da vida no município dele
votando que a lei vai passar e ele,
enfim, a gente não quer, a gente não
quer saber o que é isso.
Além desse problema prático, tem também
um problema que é o seguinte, porque a
gente fala muito do problema que é a
pessoa ter informação privilegiada ou
manipular e ganhar dinheiro em cima
disso. Ou o contrário, eh, a pessoa que
vota para eh mudar as ods ali parecer
que um candidato tem mais viabilidade,
ou seja, tanto a manipulação da pessoa
que tem muito dinheiro, quanto também a
pessoa que tem uma informação e vai
ganhar muito dinheiro. Tem esses dois
problemas. Mas tem um terceiro tipo de
apostador que é o mais comum, que não é
nem o que sabe demais e quer ganhar
dinheiro, nem o que tem dinheiro demais
e quer mudar a notícia.
é a grande maioria dos apostadores que
são os duros, os bobos, os eh viciados,
os é a imensa maioria de pessoas
>> que aposta as vítimas e são
>> é quem vai se endividar, é quem vai se
deprimir, é quem vai se matar,
>> porque já existe um aumento de suicídios
relacionados a Bet. Isso é comprovado.
Existe um problema de saúde pública
gerado por Bet. Sem falar um problema de
endividamento das pessoas por causa de
bet, tá? Afinal de contas são dezenas de
bilhões de reais que vão para as bets de
pessoas sobretudo duras. Isso a grande
maioria. O apostador não é o bilionário,
tá? Até porque não tem tanto bilionário
no Brasil. E os bilionários geral são
malandros o suficiente para saber que
não se ganha da casa de apostas, né? A
não ser que você seja o dono da casa de
apostas, a não ser que você tenha uma
informação privilegiada. Então eles
quando apostam e a maioria das pessoas
que apostam são pessoas que estão
achando que sabem mais do que sabem. São
pessoas que estão com vício ali da
dopamina ou do que for. São pessoas que
perderam emprego e estão precisando de
um dinheiro agora. Então usam apost como
se fosse um um uma saída de emergência
para uma grana que pode pintar agora
para pagar uma conta que não tá
conseguindo pagar. são pessoas em estado
de desespero. Então, vamos ser sinceros,
é, são essas pessoas que financiam
também o mercado de oposto. Então, tem
formação privilegiada, tem, tem pessoas
querendo manipular, tem, mas tem
sobretudo uma nação de pessoas que
perderam a esperança de assensão social
através do trabalho, porque realmente é
muito difícil ascender socialmente no
Brasil através do trabalho. sempre são
pessoas que perderam a perspectiva de
futuro e curiosamente agora estão
apostando e vão entrar no mercado do
futuro, que é um mercado que vive de
acabar com o futuro delas justamente.
Então é um
>> cancelamento de futuro, né? Falando em
cancelamento do futuro,
>> exatamente, a gente fala muito de
cancelamento de futuro nesse programa,
né? Que é aquela ideia meio que não é do
Mark Fisher, a ideia, o termo
>> Mark Fisher, é
>> Mark Fisher de que as pessoas não
acreditam mais no futuro por causa da
mudança climática, né? Então ela abortou
o futuro a longo prazo das pessoas.
Ninguém faz plano para aqui a 100 anos
porque não acreditam que o mundo vai
existir. Eh, então
o, curiosamente, após o cancelamento do
futuro, vem a mercantilização,
não do futuro, mas da opinião sobre o
futuro, né? Então, é muito distópico
mesmo e me entristece muito que a gente
tá numa pandemia mesmo de problema de
saúde mental e que isso certamente não
vai ajudar. Então tem as consequências
macro claro
>> tem as consequências macro, Trump,
Bolsonaro, Trump políticas, mas tem as
consequências micro também de milhões de
pessoas que vão se [ __ ] vão se [ __ ]
>> Greg, eu concordo plenamente e acho que
quando a gente olha os dados específicos
dos custos de saúde das bees, isso fica
mais iluminador, é, é muito iluminador
olhar para esses dados. Mas antes de dar
os dados, eu queria só enfatizar que uma
das preocupações justamente em relação a
esse mercado de previsão é que eles
estão dando uma roua, uma roupagem assim
mais chique, mais faria liner. É isso,
pro bom e velho vício em jogo. Eh, tanto
que o partes, a gente tá aqui falando de
política, tá falando de aposta em
relação à vida pessoal, de celebridades,
mas o boom mesmo desse mercado veio
exatamente do mesmo lugar que as bets
usaram para crescer, que é aposta
esportiva. E por que aposta esportiva?
Porque esporte é essa área da vida em
que um monte de gente acha que entende
muito, sabe? Você tem muito muito
técnico de poltrona assim, né? Muita
gente que sobretudo esse público mais
masculino que acha que sabe tudo daquele
assunto e é por isso que é especialmente
viciante. E hoje cerca de 80% das
transações da C são aposta esportiva.
Então eles realmente se parecem muito
com a Bet, inclusive no objeto principal
das apostas, que é o que se conecta com
esse público mais popular, que tende a
ser um público menos informado acerca
dos riscos de se apostar nesse tipo de
ambiente. Os dados então são, segundo o
Instituto de Políticas para eh de
Estudos para Políticas de Saúde do IEPS,
eh a gente tem um custo social anual de
cerca de R$ 38 bilhões deais eh
associados às apostas e jogos de azar.
Esse são 17 bilhões são de mortos por
suicídio, 10.4 bilhões por perda de
qualidade de vida decorrente de
depressão e 3 bilhões em tratamentos
médicos para depressão. Eh, e essas
estimativas envolvem alguns custos
diretos pro governo, né? Em contraste, a
arrecadação desse setor foi de cerca de
6.8 bilhões eh esse ano até setembro.
Então assim, o fato é que não vale a
pena pro herário público, pensando de
forma puramente fria, não vale a pena.
Mesmo que você tá, né, que tem essa essa
política arrecadatória, que foi a
política que o governo brasileiro optou
por instaurar, ela é uma política burra,
porque você arrecada um pouco mais, mas
você acaba gastando muito mais lidando
com as externalidades negativas desse
tipo de mercado. Então isso é uma coisa.
A outra que me ocorre quando você fala,
que eu acho que tem uma coisa filosófica
aí também que é mais difícil de
determinar assim, mas que é que eu diria
da eu eu colocaria da seguinte forma, eu
acho que a gente tá num momento na
história da humanidade mesmo, um momento
na nossa vida, na nossa geração, que é
um momento em que a gente precisa
trabalhar por futuros cada vez mais
improváveis. Se a gente for olhar
friamente a trajetória, por exemplo, em
que a humanidade tá em relação às
mudanças climáticas, ela é uma
trajetória que torna improvável que a
gente tenha um mundo melhor daqui a 30
anos. A probabilidade é menor do que a
probabilidade de vitória nessa luta, né?
A gente tá perdendo em muitas frontes e,
no entanto, a gente precisa lutar pelo
resultado positivo. A gente não pode
desistir desse futuro melhor, cada vez
mais improvável. A gente não pode
desistir de um futuro em que uma
democracia mais resiliente, mais forte,
capaz de entregar resultados melhores
paraa sua população. Apesar disso
parecer cada vez mais improvável quando
a gente olha para esse congresso, por
exemplo. E se você começa a ter uma
maneira de ganhar dinheiro, não com o
futuro que você quer, mas com o futuro
que você aposta que será o futuro
realizado, você pode também tá tirando,
>> que é o mais provável, você tá tirando
uma, você tá criando outras motivações
para o conformismo. E isso é muito
sutil, isso não vai ser objeto de
discussão, de regulação, mas eu acho
filosoficamente muito central, sabe? É
muito triste quando as pessoas começam a
ganhar dinheiro com os futuros terríveis
que a gente mesmo tá desenhando pra
gente sabe?
É, é culturalmente é muito e é
culturalmente é muito trágico. E isso é
um em parte o que o Mark Fisher falava
que era o cancelamento do é futuro no no
fato, porque ele falava um pouco de
mudança é climática, mas quando ele
escreveu o livro mesmo sobre o
cancelamento do futuro, era uma
perspectiva cultural e filosófica, em
que ele falava que a superestrutura
cultural, internet, mas a produção
musical, a própria indústria, a lógica e
comercial que foi invadindo tudo isso,
fez com que a o com que a eh com que a
cultura ela não conseguisse mais mais e
mais produzir vi o efeito visionário
dentro da sociedade,
>> não como produção artística, mas como
efeito psíquico dentro das cabeças das
pessoas que eram capazes de se
visualizar em um futuro radicalmente
diferente, que é o que a música era
capaz de provocar, o que a pintura já
foi capaz de provocar, o que a poesia
era capaz de provocar, que eram coisas
muito mais decisivas e sérias na
produção de futuro mesmo. E a e a
cultura parou de produzir isso, uma por
excesso, mas por um ciclo que mordia o
próprio rabo na própria indústria, no
próprio comércio, na autorreferência, na
ironia. E uma série de fatores que são
muito sutis, mas que cancelaram nossa
capacidade de imaginar um é futuro. E aí
é isso. Os caras botam incentivos
econômicos em uma sociedade já cínica e
uma sociedade que todo idealismo, sou
ingênuo, bobo, cringe, brega. E aí você
tem interesse financeiro em que o mundo
siga no caminho provável dele. Perfeito.
>> E essa é uma observação bem astuta
mesmo, cara, porque o que a gente
precisa mesmo é apostar no que a gente
tem menos chance de eh ganhar, não por
interesses econômicos,
>> mas interesse de sobrevivência mesmo,
né?
>> Sim. E o que eu acho curioso é que eles,
embora falem muito sobre crowdsourcing
ou sei lá qual os termos que usam para
dizer que tem a maior parte a gente tá
unindo os saberes do mundo e é
democrático e todo mundo tá participando
e usam muitos termos como participativo
e tal, ele não tem menor interesse em
democracia participativa, não tem menor
interesse em ouvir essa população,
porque a imensa maioria da população,
não só do Brasil como do mundo, eu
chutaria, dos Estados Unidos, certamente
também, acham que a aposta tem que ser
proibida, aposta esportiva. Nem vamos
entrar nessa seara de se a pessoa vai
engravidar ou não. A aposta esportiva
tem que ser proibida no Brasil. Imensa
maioria da população defende isso. 65%,
tá? Diz que deveria ser proibida. As
bets tem que ser proibidas. Eh, então,
já que você tá interessado na população,
na opinião, vamos vamos trair a verdade.
A verdade é essa. Então, já que você
acha que a opinião tá na maioria, da
verdade tá essa. Só que eles não estão
interessados na verdade, né? Então, eh,
dito isso, gente, eu tenho que ir, mas
se vocês quiserem, eu vou deixar vocês
aqui com o povo até para dar dicas de
livros e filmes que eu vou, tem que
cuidar das minhas filhas agora que estão
sozinhos ali. Então, ah, [risadas]
falando nisso, falando nisso, cuidar das
minhas filhas, gente, licença
paternidade não foi votada ainda. Não é
prioridade para esse governo que
empurrou a votação de licença
paternidade. Não é prioridade. A gente
teve inclusive pessoas da oposição
sinalizando que votariam a favor, mas
não é prioridade para o próprio governo.
Aparentemente tem dedo inclusive do Rui
Costa que falou assim: "Vamos votar isso
não, que vai dar um rombo no orçamento,
tal". Foi o que eu soube internamente.
Então, governo, cadê a priorização da
licença paternidade? E leis que
obriguem, leis que que a que ajudem e
que permitam que a paternidade seja mais
presente, né? Então, licença paternidade
tá já em pauta, já existe a lei, é só
votar. Estão empurrando com a barriga.
Cadê? Vamos votar licença paternidade
aí. Dito isso, tem cuidado das minhas
filhas. Um beijo, gente. Até mais. Então
ficaram dois, né Bruno? Só nós dois
aqui. Para terminar, eu vou ter que jáar
também, gente. Estou aqui no no coração
do império
>> vivendo a distopia no seu âmago, no seu
estômago. É muitos tópicos. Os Estados
Unidos são cada vez mais distópicos
mesmo.
>> Eu sei. Eu fui para ele, mas tem que
fazer promover. Fiquei bem. É isso.
Ainda temos esse ainda temos esse esse
esse poder.
>> Eh, e achei engraçado o Gregório faz
essa essa conexão conhe essa paternidade
antes de ir embora, que é justamente um
caso em que o mais provável é aquilo que
a gente não gostaria que acontecesse. E
perguntar para as pessoas o que elas
acham que vai acontecer é profundamente
diferente de perguntar o que elas
gostariam que acontecesse,
>> né? Essa essa distinção também é muito
importante. Uma pesquisa de opinião
sobre em quem que você vai votar para
presidente. É, essa é uma pergunta
radicalmente diferente de quem você acha
que vai ganhar a presidência. são coisas
diferentes. E e me deixa de novo,
voltando para meu ponto lá do início,
muito triste que as melhores cabeças do
mundo estejam hoje dedicadas não a
ajudar a gente a resolver esse
grandíssíssimo problema, que é como que
a gente toma decisões sobre o mundo que
a gente quer ver de forma mais efetiva,
o mundo que a gente quer construir de
forma mais efetiva e não e né, e e sim
dedicando o seu tempo a um a um problema
que não é um problema para ninguém, que
é como é que a gente ganha dinheiro em
cima daquilo que a gente aposta que vai
acontecer.
>> Isso não é uma questão assolando a
humanidade. Então, se eu pudesse fazer
aqui um apelo pra Luana Lara, é,
aproveita que ficou rica, vende logo
suas ações aí na caus, se libera desse
estorvo e vai dedicar sua cabecinha a
pensar no futuro da humanidade, da
democracia. Precisamos de você, Luana.
Pessoas brilhantes trabalhando com
coisas importantes. É muito necessário.
>> E aí mesmo Bruno vai discordar de mim.
Bruno, acho que a Bruna deveria parar de
pensar na humanidade, que problema dos
bilionários. Eu acho, eu acho, eu acho
que tem que ser proibido de pensar no
futuro da humanidade. E eu discordo de
você que eu acho assim, eu eu acho que
no no estado que o mundo tá, tá, tá em
2025, a gente já não tem mais, assim, a
gente não tá mais em um mundo que tem
disputas de grandes questões, assim, a
gente tá num num momento de de saldo e
de grandes conclusões no fim das contas,
especialmente nessas grandes questões
gigantescas, humanitárias e tal, de da
própria humanidade. Uhum. E eu acho meio
errado chamar uma pessoa só porque ela
fez MIT, fez astronomia, na saava bala,
é bem que ela é brilhante, entendeu? Eu
acho que tá na hora da gente começar a
colocar uma dimensão é moral muito muito
firme na hora de chamar uma pessoa de
inteligente, de brilhante hoje em dia,
entendeu? Hum.
>> Eh, especialmente hoje em dia. Então
assim, uma pessoa só que ela é boa de
exatas e tirou muito boas eh notas, mas
chega à conclusão de que vai usar essa
energia dela para fazer isso, eu me
recuso a achar que essa pessoa é é tipo
sequer inteligente, entendeu? Eu acho
que ela tá no campo dos oportunistas,
eh, que vem uma brecha real, essa sim,
real, mas não é uma brecha visionária, é
uma brecha muito bem conhecida, que
depende de acesso, que depende de alguma
inteligência de eh de eh de exatas, mas
eu acho que depende muito mais de falta
de vergonha na cara do que de
inteligência mesmo, entendeu? Porque eu
acho que se boa parte das pessoas que
com que eu me relaciono, se elas não
tivessem nenhum centro é moral, elas
seriam possivelmente muito mais ricas
hoje do que elas são, porque tá cheio de
brecha para picareta
>> penetrar nesse mundo de um capitalismo
sem nenhum escrúpulo hoje em dia, que
nem emprego mais gera. E esse é o ponto.
Ela não construiu uma grande empresa.
>> Ela não gere.000
pessoas. Ela não inventou um produto,
ela viu uma brecha algorítmica
e política para se dar bem. Se o Biden
fosse presidente dos Estados Unidos, ela
não tava bilionária, gente. Vamos deixar
uma coisa bem clara aqui, entendeu?
Então assim, eu me recuso e eu não quero
essas pessoas discutindo mais filosofia.
Eu não aguento mais ver CEO de de casa
de predição de eh de eh aposta, dando
uma entrevista em painéis com 5.000
pessoas falando sobre o que que a
democracia é o que que a verdade é e é
como é que a gente afere o fato e a
verdade. Quem é você para falar isso,
cara? Quem é você para falar isso? Qual
aula que você frequentou?
O qual qual qual leitura você tem de
isso? assim, qual a vida que você levou
para falar sobre o que que a verdade é?
Você tem 27 anos e tá tentando ficar é
bilionário. Eu acho que desde os 23.
Então para, entendeu? Eu não quero ela
conversando sobre democracia. Vai se
catar. Tá cheio de gente inteligente,
entendeu? Cheio de gente inteligente que
tem muito mais o que falar do que essa
pessoa que na minha opinião tinha que
est respondendo é processo, entendeu? e
tá com as contas bloqueadas, bem
honestamente. É isso que eu acho.
>> Não, Bruni, eu não tiro da sua razão,
não. Eu tô, eu tô falando isso, mas eh
menos em relação especificamente a
Luana, que de novo eu não conheço. E
quando eu [risadas] digo que eu suponho
que seja,
>> né? E não, mas eu digo, não só não
conheço pessoalmente, o que é meio
óbvio, mas não não conheço o suficiente
sobre ela mesmo. Uma figura que até
muito recentemente não era uma figura
conhecida do público e a nossa apuração
é limitada e as nossas chan ouvi-la no
debate público também são limitadas.
aliás, limitadas demais, dado o a
importância
do modelo que ela tá propondo. Eu acho
que o que falta, na verdade muito é,
como eu falei antes, né, mais escrutinho
do público em relação justamente aos
criadores desses modelos que podem
inserir novas distorções na maneira como
a própria sociedade se organiza. Se você
é alguém que tem a pretensão de criar
uma nova forma de se chegar à verdade,
então você precisa estar aberto a ter
uma discussão muito séria, né, com o
público sobre o que isso significa antes
de colocar o seu produto no mundo, né?
Então acho que tem um uma distorção aí.
Quando eu digo que eu suponho que seja
uma pessoa brilhante, é que acho que e e
realmente você tem razão, parte da
inteligência também é o compasso moral.
Eu acho que a gente não deveria
dissociar essas duas coisas, mas
claramente não é alguém com pouca
capacidade de execução, com pouca
capacidade de ir atrás de um de
perseguir objetivos relativamente
complexos. E, e o, e quando eu olho pro
mundo hoje, e aí eu não tô mais me
referindo a ela, eu tô falando como a
gente se organizou mesmo como sociedade.
Uma das coisas que mais me entristecem é
que as profissões, aonde a gente tem a
maior capacidade de entregar valor pro
outro, pra humanidade, aliviar
sofrimento, ajudar quem precisa, pensar
em soluções para problemas complexos,
essas são as profissões mais
desvalorizadas inclusive
financeiramente. E a gente tá
remunerando de forma obscenamente,
pornograficamente boa, gente que dedica
a sua capacidade criativa, sua
capacidade de produção, a sua
inteligência, a atividades altamente
predatórias e até perversas,
>> como é o caso desse modelo de negócio.
>> É, não? E se usou um outro termo que eu
também vou eh apontar uma certa
divergência, falou: "Elas estão sendo
remuneradas". Ela tá, é, tipo, nós não
estamos remunerando essas pessoas, a
gente tá sendo extraído. Essas pessoas
estão tipo sugando grana, grana que no
fim das contas é meio sempre pública.
Esse é o dinheiro que tá caindo
produtividade. Esse é o dinheiro que tá
faltando não só nos e cofres públicos,
mas na vida das das eh pessoas mesmo,
né? É tipo, são as pessoas que estão
ficando bilionárias em tempo record. É
esse dinheiro que tá sendo extraído e a
gente celebrando. Enfim, tô tô me tô me
repetindo. Vamos. Eu vou terminar, eu
queria terminar a a conversa sobre a C
lendo uma coisa que a Cus, que o Tareek
Mansur, que é o cofundador da C, eh,
postou no LinkedIn quando ele tava
procurando novas novos empregados, né,
novas pessoas para trabalhar na empresa.
E eu sempre gosto para, a gente até fez
isso no Gragnit quando a gente fez um
programa sobre Ray Food, é sempre
interessante ver a linguagem que as
corporações usam quando elas estão
tentando se relacionar com a sua força
de trabalho ou atrair gente pra força de
trabalho,
>> porque tem um um momento eh cultural
mesmo na forma como as grandes
corporações fazem a gestão dos seus dos
seus empregados, eh, que parece requerer
que esse que essa força de trabalho
acredite que ela tá trabalhando por algo
muito muito profundamente bom e
necessário e importante que ela tenha
propósito. Então, é é nesse momento de
atrair força de trabalho que as
corporações muitas vezes usam a sua
linguagem mais pomposa. É sempre
curioso. E aí o Tarec Mansur fala assim,
eu vou traduzir aqui mal porcamente, tá?
Caus levantou 1 bilhão de dólares eh com
uma um valuation de 11 bilhões. Uma
década atrás, apenas algumas eh algumas
pessoas no mundo sabiam que uma um
mercado de previsão era. Apenas 18 meses
atrás, a maior parte dos mercados de
previsão estavam previsão estavam
banidas até a gente conseguir overcome
the governments, né? até a gente
conseguir superar o governo ou ou enfim,
é superar o obstáculo do governo para
libertá-los. Eles libertaram os mercados
de previsão. Olha que bonito.
Eu vou ler inglês e aí retraduzir de
novo essa frase. Acho essa frase a
melhor de todos.
B over
até a gente superar o governo para
libertá-los, que é a forma mais cínica
possível de você se referir é até a
gente contratar o filho do presidente
para ganhar influência suficiente dentro
de um governo mafioso para poder
regularizar uma atividade que
provavelmente deveria continuar sendo
banida. Enfim, eh, no nos últimos 7 anos
a nossa comunidade eh abriu, a nossa
comunidade abriu uma nova categoria.
Hoje a Cauch é confiada, usada e amada,
amada por milhões de pessoas. Ela é uma
parte da da cultura do dia a dia e ela
está eh conduzindo um dos uma das
maiores mudanças em comportamento do
consumidor na história recente.
O tempo finalmente chegou para os
mercados de previsão chegarem no seu
full potential, né, no seu potencial
máximo. E a gente tem todas as intenções
de fazer isso acontecer para todas as
pessoas que acreditam e para os early
adopters, obrigado. É isso. Eu só quero
terminar com isso, com essa mensagem do
Tarek Mansu para você entrar.
>> Isso. E você sabe e você sabe o que me
vem na cabeça? Já me vê algumas vezes
essa imagem quando eu vejo o Sanutman
falando sobre inteligência, é artificial
com essa linguagem
pomposa, mas quando ele fala que ele tá
libertando uma força que ele tá
liberando, eu que não sou muito
espiritual, eu que não sou muito
religioso, você sabe bem, mas eu tenho a
sensação de que eles estão é conjurando
demônios no fim das contas, [risadas]
eles estão tentando levantar forças das
profundezas. É, tipo assim, é o BP de
Rosiméria, a gente tá fazendo um esforço
muito grande e eu consegui agora, eu fiz
o ritual, eu tô e sabe, tem uma coisa,
tipo assim, a gente precisa liberar
essas forças que estão sendo contidas
pelo grande bom senso da sociedade
democrática que fala: "Cara, a gente não
quer encostar nesses
nesses demônios, nessa inteligência
artificial, nessa financeiriação de tudo
aqui."
E só para dar uma outra informação
última que acho que a nossa Luía tá aqui
nos bastidores e deu uma informação
super importante, não é à toa que eles
usam essa linguagem de markets e de a
mercado, é porque eles são regulados
como bolsa de valores, como mercado de
ação.
>> Então, porque eles são regulados como
mercado de ação, eles precisam afirmar
que não são bets e usar a linguagem de
mercados. Mas é muito estranho você
chamar de mercado
>> uma pergunta que tem uma aposta, né?
Então assim, isso é uma questão,
>> mas só para falar que eu acho que esses
caras eles têm uma pulsão mesmo. Por
isso que eu acho que no fim das contas
tem uma questão é moral muito séria que
a gente tá enfrentando na nossa geração
mesmo e que essas potencialidades que
estão sendo liberadas, elas estão nesse
campo, num campo que o que o volume de
grana que eles são capazes de levantar
me parece muito mais uma força demoníaca
que tá se manifestando do que uma
economia de fato sendo construída.
Porque os empregos e a renda e a melhora
e a produtividade, o progresso não se
realizam com essas situações, com esses
produtos que estão sendo colocados no
mercado. Nem produtos são, eles são
dinâmicas novas de política e de e de
hábitos e neurologia, entendeu? E é
nesse lugar que esses caras estão
ficando bilionários a troco da nossa
saúde política, democrática e psíquica
mesmo.
E
>> e com isso acho que a gente pode
encerra. Vamos de hoje, né, Bruno? Vamos
dar nossas dicas. Vai lá. Você
>> não passei a última semana aqui
completamente capturada pelo mercado do
entretenimento.
>> Eh, esse mercado em [risadas] franco, em
em franca transformação, em franca
consolidação. Em franca consolidação.
>> E e é isso. Então, hoje eu não vou vou
ficar sem dicas. Já é você, Bru.
>> Não, eu a dica que eu teria para dar, eu
não vou dar porque é um livro em inglês
que não tem nada que ver com a nossa.
Não, é que eu eu tô lendo um livro
maravilhoso que eu recomendo que você
leia. Também recomendei ao seu marido,
>> The Lord of All the Dead, que é um livro
do Javier Cercas, um livro escrito em
espanhol, não tem em português, então tô
lendo ele em inglês.
>> Brumas, fala em espanhol o nome que
talvez pra nossa audiência seja legal
ler em espanhol também.
>> Eu acho que o nome é El Monarca
de las Sombras, eh, o último livro do
Javier Cercas, eh, que é um grande
escritor espanhol, já escreveu eh um
livro de ficção, acho que sobre a guerra
civil espanhola. E esse é um livro que
não é exatamente uma é ficção, foi um
livro que ele hesitou em escrever a vida
dele toda, que é sobre o tio avô dele,
que morreu na Guerra Civil Espanhola com
é 19 anos nas eh falanges, defendendo o
fascismo espanhol. E é um livro lindo,
porque é uma reconstrução de memória
dele, tentando chegar nesse parente
mitológico da família dele, mas dessa
vergonha que ele tinha de ter um
parente, de ter uma família com laços
com ovo fascismo.
Mas é também essa tentativa de eh
reconstruir essa maneira íntima como um
jovem pode se tornar
fascista e essas grandes forças é
sociais que foram culminando em um em um
mundo dos anos 30 em que a crença no
liberalismo e na república e na
democracia e no capitalismo estavam se
esfacelando e novas utopias e novas
maneiras de se imaginar o mundo estavam
sendo produzidas e disputadas de maneira
violenta. E acho que isso dialoga muito
com a nossa época de uma maneira
estranha, mas muito decisiva, assim,
então é um livro que eu tô lendo, eh,
espero que saia em português. É, e
também recomendo a todo mundo que tiver
algum interesse, quem não conhece e
mergulhar um pouco hoje no na obra do
grande Martin Par, grande fotógrafo que
ontem faleceu, eh, um gênio da
fotografia, um cara muito único, muito
insubstituível, mas muito importante na
eh na linguagem visual, acho que dos
últimos 30 40 anos. Então, quem tiver um
tempinho hoje para entrar na obra do
Martin Par a A R, tipo, recomendo muito
como maneira de homenageá-lo.
>> E clube de clube de cultura do
Calmogente no ano que vem pra gente ter
esse tipo de papo mais em profundidade
sobre livros, séries e o significado de
tudo isso e para manter o nosso podcast
no ar em 26.
>> É isso, gente. Vai lá em
calmongente.com, quem quiser se
inscrever. Estamos quase no finzinho do
ano. Ainda dá para aproveitar o nosso
desconto de 10% que vai só até o Natal.
Um beijo em todo mundo. Tchau, Bru.
[música]
>> O Calma Urgente é uma produção da Peri
Produções. Na apresentação temos eu,
Alessandro Rofino, o Gregório do Vivier
e o Bruno Tortura. Na coordenação de
produção, Carolina Foratina Igreja. Na
pesquisa, roteiro e apuração, Luía
Miguez. Na captação, edição e mixagem,
Víor Bernardes. Na Ilustração, Ana
Brandão. Na sonoplastia, Felipe Croco.
Nas redes sociais, Teodora do Vivier e
Bruna Messina. Na gestão da nossa
comunidade, Marcela Brandes. A nossa
identidade visual foi feita por Pedro e
Noei e a nossa consultoria de
comunicação é da Luna Costa.
[música]